[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Mine Cetinkaya-Rundel.
I'm a professor at Duke
University and a developer
educator at Posit.
And in this video
I'd like to talk
to you a little bit about how
I use Quarto as an academic.
We're going to
focus on two parts
of my life as an
academic-- how I
use Quarto as part
of my teaching,
and how I use Quarto
as part of my research.
So let's start
with the teaching.
We're going to turn
to RStudio and take
a look at this
document, a simple HTML
document with some code
chunks where we create
a figure and then a table.
So let's go ahead and
render this document.
To take a quick
look at the output,
we're doing a very
simple data analysis
with the lovely
palmerpenguins package here.
And we'll be able to see
that there are already
some things built
into the document
I'm using: some hyperlinks
and whatnot in my document.
I have some cross references
in my document as well.
And what we're going
to do next is enhance
this document for teaching use.
Now, let's suppose
that you are teaching
coding to your students.
One of the things that's
often helpful to do
is to encourage them to read
the documentation for functions
whenever possible.
And generally we
tell our students,
why don't you
Google the function?
I think we can do one better.
So one of the nice
functionalities of Quarto
is that we can actually
add automatic hyperlinks
to each of our functions.
So what I'm doing
is in the YAML I
am adding a new field called
"code link," and let's go ahead
and render that.
And here we go.
We can see that each of our R
functions are now hyperlinks.
So if I was to click on
a function like library,
I get directed to the
HTML documentation
for that function.
And let's go ahead
and click on something
that is from the tidyverse.
For example, what
does geom_point do?
So for one of these packages
that has a pkgdown site,
the code link takes me
directly to the documentation
for that function.
And particularly
for ggplot functions
these are extremely helpful,
because then your students
can scroll down to
the examples and not
only see the examples as
part of the documentation,
but the rendered versions
of those plots as well.
Next let's go and
do something else.
We are going to add
a code chunk option.
And I am going to say I want
to hide this code chunk,
and I want to hide any of its
warnings and messages as well.
So in order to do that, I
will say, include false,
and let's go ahead
and render this.
We can see that it
doesn't render because I
have made a syntax error.
But the nice thing in
the context of teaching,
particularly your
student's learning Quarto,
and particularly if they're
coming at it from having
learned R Markdown
previously, is
that when you make a
syntax error like this,
the message that you get
from Quarto is really useful,
and it tells you exactly
where the issue is.
And so let me go
ahead and fix that.
I should be using a
semicolon instead.
And once I do that,
if I click on the tab,
I can actually use YAML
completion to make sure
that I am typing "false"
in exactly the way
Quarto expects me to.
And we can see here
now that that code
chunk where we're loading
packages is not in our output
anymore.
So as a professor, one of
the things I do regularly
is go from writing
course notes or a book
at times to writing slides
for in-class teaching.
And it's really useful when
I can use the same source
document as a starting point for
each of these different venues.
And with Quarto, it's
really neat that you can
without having to change any
of the text in your document,
simply by changing your format.
So in this case, we
will make this reveal.js
to create HTML-based slides.
It's going to ask us to
reload our visual editor.
And let's go ahead and render
and see what that looks like.
All right.
And now we have a
slide deck version
of our document with
a handy sidebar tool.
And one of the things
that I really enjoy here
is that I can not only
make my slides full screen
or take a look at
a speaker view,
but a question I get asked
very often from my students
is, can we get a PDF
version of the slides
so that they can annotate
on it, say, on their tablets
or something.
And there is a neat PDF export
mode that they can click on
and they can immediately
get the PDF export
should they want to print
it or save it as a PDF file.
Next, let's take a
look at how might I
use Quarto in the context of
teaching in the classroom.
Oftentimes I am
teaching in a classroom
where there's a projector screen
behind me that happens to cover
the whiteboard, for example.
Or a student asks a question
and what I really want to do
is draw on my slides.
Maybe something like, if I
scroll to the figure here,
maybe something where I
want to annotate my slides
and show the three
clusters of penguins.
I can do this by adding
fields to my YAML again.
So under reveal.js let's
do "chalkboard true"
and render this again.
And you can see that in
addition to the little hamburger
menu for the tools
on the sidebar,
I have gained two
new tools here.
One of them is an
annotation tool.
I'm going to go ahead
and click on that,
click a color that
I might want to use,
and I can then use that
to annotate my slides.
And the neat thing
is you can actually
save an annotated version
of your slides as well.
So if you tend to annotate
on your slides a lot,
maybe do some derivations
as you go through the class
and then would like to
post an annotated version
of your slides, you
could save those.
I'm going to go ahead and
remove these annotations
by clicking on the Delete
button on my keyboard.
And now let's get to that
point where I actually
want to write
something on the board,
maybe not just
annotate my slides,
but there is no board to
be seen in the classroom.
So I can click on
the Chalkboard option
and basically start typing,
start writing and annotating
on my chalkboard as well.
And I'm going to go ahead
and get rid of that too now.
Another handy tool is one where
as you advance your slides,
the posted version of
your slides advance
along with you as well.
This can be particularly
helpful for students maybe
who may have lost where you
were at in that lecture,
so that as you advance
through your slides,
if they have it open
on their computers,
they can follow along.
In order to do that, I'm going
to add the multiplex option
to my slides.
And when we render
this, we can see
that we have now gained two
outputs to our slide deck.
One of them is
just penguins.html,
which is what we
had before as well,
and the other one is
penguins-speaker.html.
So what you want to do is you
want to be posting the .HTML
version on, say,
your course website,
but you want to be presenting
from your "-speaker" version,
and that way, as you
advance your slides,
they will advance for
your audience as well.
By default, when we
look at our HTML slides,
you'll see that the code
is not visible here.
The reveal.js mode by
default hides your code,
which is not helpful
if you're actually
trying to teach the code.
So let's go ahead and
turn all of that code
on using the execute option
in our document YAML.
You can see that
I can control here
a bunch of things about
how the code is executed,
so I'm going to go ahead
and set that to true,
and let's go ahead and render
the document one more time.
I can see my code,
and underneath it
I can see the table output.
If we go back to
the previous slide
where I have some lengthy
ggplot code, and suppose that
I want to give some
insight into this code.
Suppose that I want to talk
a little bit about what
the scale_color_colorblind
function does and then maybe
a little bit about what
these theme functions do.
So I might want to highlight
my code, so let's go ahead
and see how we can do that.
In the relevant
code chunk I'm going
to add a code chunk option
that says, "code line numbers,"
and in here I am going to say
that a vertical bar to indicate
a pause.
I want to first talk
about line number nine.
That's the
scale_color_colorblind.
And then I want to talk
about lines 10 to 11.
And let's render this again.
If I now advance
my slides, I'll see
that first, line number
nine is highlighted,
so I can talk a
little bit about that.
And then I advance
again, and I can
see that now lines 10
and 11 are highlighted,
and I can render them again.
The neat thing about
this is that we
are able to specify this
as one of our chunk options
as opposed to having
to edit our code
and add syntax to the
code chunk itself.
Now, the problem
here, though, is
that my plot is really
squished because reveal.js
is giving the space
for the code chunk
itself and then using
whatever space is available
that's left over in this slide
for that plot, which is not
very helpful.
One approach to
solving this would
be to create another code chunk
that references this one using
its label, but a neat
Quarto solution to this
is to use the code chunk
option Output Location.
And I can choose to--
the default means
that the output
is going to show up
underneath your code chunk.
Fragment means it's going
to appear when you advance
the slides, and the
Slide option says
to put the output
on the next slide.
So let's select that so that
we can get a nice big plot
on the next slide.
All right.
So I have just my
code on this slide.
I can advance through and
see the highlighted versions
of portions of that code.
And now my plot itself has
moved to the next slide.
Now suppose that
you are actually
using Quarto to teach Quarto.
You actually want to
show your students
how you can add all of
these code chunk options.
In the rendered
document they are
impossible to see since
they're hidden from the output.
But we can easily reveal those
by adding a new code chunk
option called "echo fenced."
And let's go ahead
and render that too.
And now our code chunk actually
prints not just the code itself
but all of the code
chunk options as well.
So I didn't have to create a
new sort of indented code chunk
or something to be
able to reveal these.
And you can see that the only
code chunk option that's not
visible here is the echo fence.
So it's smart enough
to hide that one
and show the rest of
the code chunk options
so you can easily talk about
how to write Quarto documents
with your learners as well.
Now we've added a lot of
options to these slides that
are very much slide specific.
Let's go back and turn things
back to an HTML document.
So I'm going to change
my format to HTML,
which asks me to reload the
visual editor one more time.
And let's go ahead
and render that again.
All right.
And let's talk about one
last code chunk option
that can be really helpful
in a teaching context,
particularly if you are writing
long-form documents, course
notes, or a book
where you might want
to annotate your code further.
I'm going to scroll down
to the very last code chunk
here where we're
creating a table,
and I'm going to add
some annotation to it.
So I might say this
is my line number one.
So the hash sign and then one.
And we're going to
basically annotate
each one of these line numbers.
And let's go ahead
and say this is four.
And right underneath
my code chunk,
I'm going to start
writing up my annotation.
So something like, "start
with the penguins data frame,
then slice the top 10 rows,
select some variables,
and make a table with gt.
This code annotation
feature that's
available with
Quarto 1.3 onwards
allows you to annotate
lines, each line of code,
and basically add some text
to it so that you can--
if you were teaching in
person, these are probably
the words you would
say about the code,
but now it's really
easy to capture them
in a written document as well.
And it doesn't have to
be one line per code.
So I could do something like
give the same annotation
number to that last
line of code and say
that I want to capture
both of those comments
in a single item in
the list underneath it.
And here we go.
That item four has
gone away, and now I
have an item three that
basically covers everything
that's underneath it.
So we've showcased a
bunch of Quarto features
that are helpful for
teaching, but what
about the research
or the publication
side of an academic slide?
So let's talk about
that a little bit next.
The neat thing about
writing papers with Quarto
is that it comes with
some article templates.
So I'm on the Quarto
documentation page here,
and I am going to scroll
down here a little bit
and go to the GitHub
repository, where
we can find a bunch of
journal templates here.
I tend to write papers that
use the American Statistical
Association journals
template, so we're
going to take a
look at that here.
If the template that you
tend to use for your papers
is already listed
here, that's fantastic.
You can get started right away.
And if not, I
encourage you to open
an issue in the repository.
Or if you're interested,
contribute the template
to the repository so that
others can use as well.
So for the JASA template,
it says to install it.
We're going to use quarto
use template, and then
quarto journals jasa.
So I'm going to copy
that line of code,
and let's go to that page
here as well, go to my RStudio
and open up my terminal.
And let's go ahead
and paste that there.
It asked me if I trust the
authors of this template.
Yes.
The directory name can
be My Awesome Paper,
and let's go ahead
and see what we got.
In my files pane here I can
see a new directory called
My Awesome Paper, and there
is a Quarto file in there
with a very extensive YAML.
And if you have written papers
before that, whether either
with R Markdown, with
the articles package,
or just using LaTeX,
know that the preamble
tends to be pretty long.
So I am going to give it a
new title, "My Awesome Paper
About Data Science,"
and maybe I can just
add my name quickly here.
And let's go ahead and
render the document.
And here we go.
The output looks
like something I'm
actually pretty used to
seeing when I write papers
using other tools as well.
And the neat thing
with this template
is that it comes with some pre
filled-in text that tells me
exactly how I might include
figures or tables in my output
and how I can even include
some citations as well.
So let's switch over
to the visual editor,
and let's talk a little
bit about citation.
So I would like to add
a citation to my paper.
Let's say that I want
to add something right
at the end of my introduction.
And I can do this
in one of two ways.
I can either use the
Insert menu and say
that I want to add a citation,
or I can use my Insert Anything
tool and say citation.
And you can see that I have
even linked up my Zotero library
here.
And so I can click on that.
I happen to have one of my
papers saved in my Zotero
library.
So if you use a tool
like Zotero or Crossref
or something like that,
you can actually link these
up to your RStudio,
and as long as you
have them running on your
computer, on the same computer,
they automatically
link up anyway,
and I can go ahead
and insert that.
So let's go ahead and save
that and render this document
one more time.
Right.
So at the end of
my introduction,
the new citation is there.
I can click on it, and I
can see that it has been
added to my list of references.
And what RStudio also did
for me at the same time
is it added that entry
to my BIB file as well.
So I can see that has already
been inserted into my BIB file.
What if you don't use
a tool like Zotero?
Or maybe you are looking for
a paper on Google Scholar.
So how about we look for the
Welcome to the Tidyverse paper.
And I'm going to go
ahead and open that up,
and we're going to grab
the DOI of this paper.
I have copied that from here.
Let's go back to
RStudio, and let's say
that we want to
add that citation,
suppose here, using the
Insert Anything tool again
and citation.
I'm going to say
this time that I want
to find a paper by its DOI.
So I paste the DOI here, and it
goes out and searches for that,
and it allows me to insert
that citation either
as an in-text citation or not.
Let's go ahead and hit Insert.
And once I have done
that, that has also
been added to my BIB file.
We can see that that's
been added to my BIB file,
and a reference has been
created for it as well.
And if I render my
document one last time,
I'll be able to see that that
citation has been inserted
to the appropriate
location as well,
and I can find the paper
in the list of references
at the end of my document.
So we've talked a bit about
using Quarto for teaching
and a little bit
about using Quarto
as part of your research.
If you've been
intrigued or if you've
already been a Quarto user and
have enjoyed these features
that I highlighted here,
there is an abundant number
of features available in Quarto
that we haven't gotten a chance
to touch on in this video.
So if you would
like to learn more,
I encourage you to
go to Quarto.org.
If you are just getting
started with Quarto,
the Get Started menu
will be helpful,
where you can learn
about how to use
Quarto using your editor
of choice, whichever
one is your favorite.
And if you have already
dived into Quarto
and know the basics, I suggest
going to the guide to dive
further into any of
the different outputs
that you might be
interested in creating,
like a website or a book
or adding interactivity
to your documents.
And to stay up to
date with what's
happening in Quarto land, the
blog is a great place to go.
Particularly when
there are new features,
they are generally
documented here.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]